welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today you
can follow me on twitter at fair and
balanced you also find me on instagram
and facebook at that same handle at fair
and balanced we've got a little bit more
Trump news to talk about today because
the man got a little bit more bad news
yesterday and that bad news came in the
form of a court ruling by Judge Amit
Mehta
who said that I'm sorry Donald and Trump
administration but I'm not going to
block the Democrats request to get your
financial documents now if you rewind
the clock about a week ago when the
Trump administration made these
arguments in court in front of Judge
Metta judge Mehta at the time basically
told Trump's lawyers that your arguments
don't hold any water because the Trump
lawyers were trying to say Democrats
can't request Donald Trump's financial
documents because it's not related to
any legislation that they're trying to
pass and Congress's job as we all know
is only to pass legislation and the
judge said no no really it's not that's
not how the separation of powers work
they actually also have oversight
authority of the executive branch and so
this would fall within the things
they're legally allowed to do even if
it's not related to legislation but then
the judge said but listen I understand
the importance of this and I'm gonna
weigh both sides of the argument so I'm
gonna look at all the evidence and I'm
gonna take some time before I hand down
this ruling because I don't want to rush
it
that was the mature responsible
professional and legally correct thing
for this judge to do and then Monday
hands down the ruling he says yeah
Republicans I thought about it and
listen your arguments they were garbage
they don't work they don't hold up it
flies in the face of the separation of
powers and so yes
therefore the Democrats 100% can get
their hands on Donald Trump's financial
records now Trump immediately got angry
he told reporters he's gonna appeal it
and he's furious that this Obama
a judge he kept calling him and Obama
appointed judge in fact one point he
said it was a recently appointed Obama
Obama judge recently so yes Obama came
out of retirement while Trump was
President to go ahead just to point this
judge the guy's been out of office for
two and a half years that's not exactly
recent Trump but nonetheless yeah
Obama did appoint this judge and this
judge 100% did what any normal
well-respected person who understands
the law would do and they smacked down
your lawyers because their argument was
absolute garbage you know there is one
theme that's developing throughout the
Trump administration and we've seen it
unfold very publicly and that is the
fact that this man has some of the worst
lawyers imaginable I mean think about it
Michael Cohen he's in jail now he will
be for the next three years Rudy
Giuliani that man actually went on TV
multiple different times and implicated
Donald Trump in crimes and that was
supposed to be his client Jay Sekulow
well we all know the story that emerged
yesterday we're going to talk about that
a little bit later in the bonus show but
Jay Sekulow apparently ordered Michael
Cohen to lie to Congress and then you
have these bonehead lawyers who go into
court acting like they don't understand
the roles that Congress constitutionally
has and the judge has to say listen you
don't seem to understand how Congress
works but they're allowed to do this
so yeah Trump clearly has a history of
hiring horrible people to be his lawyers
and to that I say please continue this
it's a lot of fun watching your lawyers
going to court and reading these filings
and seeing how clueless they are and how
desperate they are to protect whatever
it is you're hiding so please continue
to hire from the bottom of the barrel
because it's making life for the rest of
us so much more entertaining but to the
actual ruling right I am NOT just the
ruling from the judge but what it means
it means as of right now but course
Trump's gonna appeal it Democrats could
get their hands on the financial records
and the big question is
obviously what the heck is Donald Trump
hiding you know he also claimed after
going after this quote Obama appointed
judge that he has had the most
transparent administration in history
he's either completely delusional or he
thinks everybody in this country is an
absolute idiot if he thinks he can get
away with saying that we can't see his
grades from college or high school we
can't see his medical records we can't
see his tax returns we can't see his
financial records we can't see his
business holdings there is nothing
transparent about Donald Trump except
his hair but nonetheless he is hiding
something
that much is pretty obvious right folks
you don't go through all of this wreck
effort you don't threaten to sue schools
if they release your grades if you're
not trying to hide something you don't
fight congressional subpoenas in court
unless you're trying to prevent Congress
from seeing something you don't want
them to see the big question is what is
he hiding is he hiding bank fraud well
representative Ted Lew made a pretty
strong case during Michael Cohen's
testimony to Congress that Donald Trump
committed bank fraud and based on the
cooperation that Deutsche Bank has had
so far with congressional Democrats it
seems pretty obvious that he inflated
his net worth in order to secure a loan
that's fraud you can't do that is there
potential money laundering now again the
folks at Deutsche Bank really seemed to
think that there was not just with Trump
but with Jared Kushner so there's that
but I think the biggest thing this man
wants to hide because I think he thinks
he can get away with any criminal
activity that doesn't bother him never
has never will as a man who's gotten
away with quite literally everything for
his entire life but what he can't get
away with is destroying his reputation
I think these financial documents would
tell us that Donald Trump does not have
as much money as he says he has and if
that were to be the case that would
absolutely destroy the image that
he has spent his entire life crafting
and there's no coming back from that you
know he could do his best to lie his way
out of criminal activity
he's already lied his way about out of
the fact that he lost all that money you
know trying to say that oh no it was
just she kind of write these numbers and
it's almost fraud but it's totally not
fraud and everybody did it except I
didn't actually do that so you did lose
the money all he did was just spew out a
bunch of words further confusing the
public and suddenly everybody split on
whether or not the man did lose the
money or if he committed fraud or if he
did pay taxes or what the hell's going
on nobody knows so he thinks he can lie
his way out of criminal activity is all
I'm trying to say but he can't lie his
way out of the fact that he may not have
as much money as he wants us to think he
does and that would destroy him it
wouldn't end his presidency but it would
absolutely deliver a blow to his ego
that I do not know this man would ever
be able to physically and emotionally
overcome because that is the thing that
matters the most to him yes this man
loves money more than I have ever seen a
human being love money but that money is
what made that ego and if we find out
that the money's not there then suddenly
his lifetime of lies creating this
facade comes crumbling to the ground and
this man would never be able to recover
from that